moins de cinq cent mille euros en 2016
près de 14 millions d'euros en 2017 et
un budget commun x 30 les départements
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
poursuivent leur rapprochement dans le
détail cette année et 12,7 millions
d'euros sont dédiés aux routes
départementales 1 million à
l'archéologie préventive et 100000 euros
au service de l'adoption les
départements versent à l'établissement
public l'argent qui était consacrée au
paravent pour remplir ses missions à
l'euro près et c'est là donc dans un peu
plus de temps dans 18 mois sans doute
quand on aura la comptabilité de
l'établissement public que l'on pourra
voir si effectivement nous avons comme
ça réaliser des économies parmi les 88
élus départementaux 6 des hauts-de-seine
classé à gauche ont voté contre le
budget primitif dans les yvelines sans
opposition politique seul philippe
brillault s'est abstenu je suis
dubitatif sur la pertinence
parce qu'en fait vendredi dernier en
votant le budget des yvelines
je n'ai pas vu l'effet miroir de la
diminution des sommes que j'ai voté
aujourd'hui si nous avons voté
aujourd'hui une somme je dois me trouver
en moins à proportions respectives de
nos chaque département je n'avais pas vu
également opposé aux arguments
économiques de la mutualisation des
agents de la cgt s'étaient rassemblés
avant le conseil d'administration de le
pays
il s'inquiète notamment pour leurs
conditions de travail